여러분, 앞으로 바다로 가는 초대형 컨테이너선이
기름을 거의 넣지 않고 움직이는 시대가 올 수도 있습니다.
배터리로 가는 전기선도 아니고
수수선이나 메타놀이나 암모니아 선박도 아닙니다.
바로 배 위에 작은 원전을 싣는 선박, SMR 추진선입니다.
SMR은 소형 모듈 원전입니다.
기존 대형 원전보다 크기를 줄이고
모듈 형태로 만들 수 있는 원자로를 말하죠.
원래는 전력 생산을 위해 많이 논의되던 기술인데
최근에는 이 SMR을 선박에 적용하려는 움직임이 빨라지고 있습니다.
오늘 영상은요, 남성들의 귀차니즘을 해결해줄
하루 한 포, 데이팩과 함께합니다.
그렇다면 왜 하필 선박일까요?
그 배경에는 해운업을 향한 강한 탈탄소 압박이 있습니다.
알다시피 대부분의 국제무역은 배를 통해 움직입니다.
그런데 이 거대한 산업은 여전히 화석연료에 크게 의존하고 있죠.
국제사기구 IMO는 2050년까지
국제해운의 온도를 높여서
해운실가스 순배출량을 제로로 만들겠다는 방향을 제시했습니다.
이제 해운사와 조선사는 단순히 연료비만 따질 수 없습니다.
앞으로는 어떤 연료를 쓰느냐에 따라
규제비용이 달라지고 운항 가능성이 달라지고
선박의 가치까지 달라질 수 있습니다.
그래서 지금 해운업에서는 여러 대안이 동시에 검토되고 있죠.
메타놀 추진선, 암모니아 추진선, 수소연료전지 선박,
배터리 전기선, 그리고 원자력 추진선입니다.
그런데 여기서 중요한 차이가 있습니다.
자동차는 배터리 전기차로 상당 부분 전환이 가능합니다.
하지만 초대형 선박은 다르죠.
컨테이너선은 태평양과 인도양을 건너야 합니다.
며칠이 아니라 몇 주 동안 항해합니다.
배안에서는 수천 개에서 수만 개의 컨테이너가 실립니다.
이 정도 크기의 선박을 움직이려면
엄청난 양의 에너지가 필요하죠.
그래서 해운업에서 가장 중요한 질문은 이겁니다.
탄소를 줄이면서도 장거리 항해가 가능하고
화물 공간을 크게 희생하지 않는 에너지가 필요하죠.
이 에너지원이 무엇인가?
메타놀과 암모니아는 중요한 대안입니다.
이미 글로벌 해운사들도 메타놀 추진선을 발주하고 있고
암모니아 엔진도 개발되고 있습니다.
하지만 이 연료들에도 한계가 있습니다.
핵심은 에너지 밀도입니다.
쉽게 말하면 같은 거리를 가기 위해
얼마나 많은 연료 공간이 필요한가의 문제입니다.
기존 중유나 LNG에 비해 메타놀, 암모니아, 수소는
저장 방식과 부피 측면에서 부담이 큽니다.
연료 탱크가 커지면 그만큼 화물을 실을 공간이 줄어들죠.
선박은 결국 많은 화물을 멀리, 안정적으로, 낮은 비용으로 운송해야 합니다.
그런데 친환경 연료를 쓰기 위해서 화물 공간이 줄어든다면
사업성이 흔들릴 수 있겠죠.
바로 이 지점에서 SMR 추진선이 등장합니다.
선박에 SMR을 적용한다는 건
배 안의 원자로가 전기를 만들고
그 전기로 모터를 돌려 배를 움직인다는 뜻입니다.
쉽게 말하면 선박 안에 장기간 운항 가능한 발전 시스템을 넣는 겁니다.
이 방식의 장점은 분명합니다.
운항 중 직접 탄소가 생기거나
탄소 배출을 크게 줄일 수 있고
황산화물이나 질소산화물 같은 대기오염물질 문제에서도 자유로워질 수 있습니다.
또 한 번 핵연료를 장전하면
오랜 기간 연료 교체 없이 운항할 수 있다는 기대도 있습니다.
중요한 건 SMR 선박의 매력이 단순히 친환경에만 있지 않다는 점입니다.
기존 선박은 항로를 짤 때 연료 보급을 고려해야 합니다.
어디서 연료를 넣을지, 연료 가격은 얼마인지,
연료 탱크 공간은 얼마나 필요한지 계속 따져야 합니다.
하지만 SMR 추진선이 실제로 가능해진다면
연료 보급 부담이 크게 줄고 선박 설계와 항로 전략도 달라질 수 있습니다.
그래서 조선사와 성급, 원전 기업들이 이 분야를 진지하게 검토하고 있는 겁니다.
한국 기업들의 움직임을 보면 방향이 조금씩 다릅니다.
HD연대는 가장 직접적으로 원자력 추진 컨테이너선을 보고 있습니다.
HD 한국 조선해양은 1만 5천 TEU급 SMR 추진 컨테이너선 모델을 공개했고
미국 성급협회 ABS와 함께
1만 6천 TEU급 컨테이너선에 원자력 기반 전기 추진 시스템을 적용하는 개념 설계를 추진하고 있습니다.
여기서 중요한 점은 군함이 아니라 민간 상선이라는 겁니다.
글로벌 물류를 담당하는 대형 컨테이너선에 원자력 추진을 적용하려는 구상입니다.
삼성중공업은 원자력으로 움직이는 컨테이너선보다는
먼저 바다 위에 떠 있는 작은 원자력 발전소에 가까운 모델을 개발하고 있습니다.
쉽게 말하면 큰 바지선 위에 SMR과 발전 설비를 올려놓고
바다 위에서 전기를 생산하는 방식입니다.
이 전기는 육지, 섬, 해상 플랜트, 수소 생산 시설 등에 공급될 수 있습니다.
이 방식은 전 세계 항구를 돌아다니는 원자력 컨테이너선보다
규제 부담이 상대적으로 작을 수 있습니다.
컨테이너선은 여러 나라 항구의 입항 허가를 받아야 하지만
해상 원전 플랫폼은 특정 해역에서 운영하는 발전 설비로 관리할 수 있기 때문입니다.
그래서 실제 상용하는 원자력 추진 컨테이너선보다
이런 해상 원전 플랫폼은
해상 원전 플랫폼 쪽에서 먼저 시작될 가능성도 있습니다.
하나오션은 MSR 기술과 연결돼서 거론됩니다.
MSR은 해결료를 액체 상태의 염에 녹여 쓰는 방식입니다.
이 경쟁은 한국만의 이야기가 아닙니다.
중국은 2만4천 TEU급 초대형 원자력 추진 컨테이너선 개념을 공개했습니다.
영국에서는 주요 해운사들이 원자력 추진선이
실제 유럽 항구에 들어올 수 있는지 규제 연구를 진행하고 있습니다.
노르웨이 울스타인은 SMR을 이용한
해상 충전용 선박 개념을 내놨습니다.
정리하면 SMR 선박은 아직 상업 운항 단계는 아니지만
이미 한국, 중국, 유럽이 다음 시장을 두고 움직이기 시작한 분야입니다.
여기서 꼭 짚어야 할 사실이 있습니다.
현재 전 세계 바다로 가는 상업용 SMR 추진 컨테이너선은 아직 없습니다.
지금 나오는 이야기들은 대부분 개념 설계, 기술 검토, 성급의 개념 승인 단계입니다.
하지만 변화는 분명하죠.
과거에는 질문이
배에 원자로를 싣는 게 가능할까였다면
지금은 가능하다면 어떤 규칙으로 운항하게 할 것인가로 바뀌고 있습니다.
국제해사기구 IMO는 오래전에 만들어진 원자력 상승 관련 규정을 다시 선보는 논의를 시작했습니다.
국제원자력기구도 해상 원자력 기술의 안전과 보완, 허가 기준을 다루기 시작했습니다.
SMR 선박이 단순한 기업 홍보 아이디어를 넘어서
국제기구와 성급이 실제 규칙을 고민하는 단계로 들어간 겁니다.
다만 여기서부터가 진짜 어려운 문제입니다.
원자력 추진선은 한 나라 안에서만 움직이지 않습니다.
컨테이너선은 여러 나라 항구에 들어가야 합니다.
그런데 각국 항만과 지역 사회가 우리 항구의 원자력 추진선을 받아들이겠다고 쉽게 결정할 수 있을까요?
기술적으로 안전하다고 해도 사람들의 불안감은 남을 수밖에 없습니다.
항만은 사고 대응 매뉴얼을 만들어야 하고 정부는 법적 기준을 정해야 하고 성급은 안전 기준을 만들어야 합니다.
보험 문제도 있습니다.
일반 선박 사고는 어느 정도 보험 체계가 잡혀 있습니다.
하지만 원자력 사고는 다릅니다.
발생 가능성이 낮더라도 한 번 사고가 나면 책임 범위와 피해 규모가 매우 커질 수 있습니다.
그래서 SMR 선박이 실제로 운항하려면 세 가지 질문에 답을 해야 합니다.
사고가 나면 누가 책임질 것인가?
보험사는 어디까지 보장할 것인가?
항구는 어떤 조건에서 입항을 허용할 것인가?
이게 정리되지 않으면 기술이 있어도 상업 운항이 가능합니다.
과거에도 미국, 독일, 일본이 원자력 상선을 시험한 적이 있습니다.
하지만 경제성, 안정성 우려, 대중의 불안 때문에 본격적인 상용화로 이어지지 못했습니다.
결국 원자력 선박은 기술의 문제이면서 동시에 실내의 문제입니다.
그렇다면 SMR 선박은 정말 상용화될 수 있을까요?
가능성은 분명히 있어 보입니다.
초대형 선박은 배터리만으로 움직이기 어렵고 메탄올이나 암모니아도 연료 저장 공간과 공급망 문제가 남아 있습니다.
그러면서 SMR은 장거리 대형 선박을 움직일 수 있는 강력한 후보입니다.
하지만 아직 확정된 미래는 아닙니다.
실제 배가 만들어지고 보험이 붙고 항구가 받아들이고 국제 규칙이 정리되어야 비로소 상용화라고 말할 수 있습니다.
SMR 선박은 K조선의 새로운 기회가 될 수도 있습니다.
하지만 그 기회는 기술을 먼저 만든 쪽이 아니라 안정성과 신뢰 그리고 국제 규칙까지 먼저 설득하는 쪽에 열릴 가능성이 큽니다.
자, 지금부터!
오늘 영상 제작에 도움을 주신 건강한 오늘 참 쉽다 데이팩 광고 큐!
여러분은 하루에 몇 가지의 영양제를 드시고 계시나요?
솔직히 이거 하나하나 다 열어서 꺼내먹기도 너무 힘들고 주방도 좁아 터져서 놔둘 자리도 부족한데 나이가 들면서 챙겨 먹어야 될 것들은 많아지고 이거 완전히 첩첩 삼중입니다.
그래서 오늘 제가 소개해드릴 제품 남성들의 귀차니즘과 필수 영양소를 챙겨줄 하루 한 포 데이팩 에너지입니다.
일단 데이팩 에너지 제품이 좋은 게 뭐냐면 패키징이 아주 야물딱지입니다.
한 박스에 31분이 들어있는데 매일매일 그냥 한 포씩 꺼내 드시기만 하면 됩니다.
이 4알이면 하루에 필요한 영양소들과 루테인, 밀크시슬, 비타민 B공까지 야무지게 섭취할 수 있죠.
보이시나요? 하루 한 포면 하루에 필요한 영양 성분을 간편하게 섭취할 수 있습니다.
다른 건강기능식품을 별도로 더 챙겨 먹을 필요가 없다는 얘기죠.
실제로 저는 요즘 이 데이팩 에너지 제품을 꾸준히 챙겨 먹고 있는데요.
평소 건강기능식품을 먹을 때 뚜껑 열고 닫는 데만 한 세월이 걸리다 보니
내 돈 주고 사놓고는 며칠 지나면 식탁 한 구석에 조용히 방치되더라고요.
그런데 데이팩 에너지는 그냥 한 포 꺼내고 뜯어서 4알만 먹으면 되니 꼬박꼬박 챙겨 먹어지더라고요.
자, 이제 간편하다는 건 확실히 알겠고 이 제품이 왜 추천할 제품인가에 대해서 설명해드리겠습니다.
첫 번째, 남성분들이 건강기능식품을 챙겨 먹는 이유는
에너지가 부족해서 아니겠습니까?
요즘은 4050 남성분들 뿐만 아니라 2030 남성분들도 옥타코사놀을 많이들 먹는다고 하는데
그 옥타코사놀, 여기 안에 들어있습니다. 중요한 건 옥타코사놀과 함께 비타민C, D, E, 엽산, 크롬, 망간, 아연, 셀레늄, 부리까지 들어있다는 겁니다.
아이고 숨차다.
두 번째, 잦은 야근과 회식으로 우리 간이 너무 불쌍하잖아요. 그래서 챙겨 드시는 게 뭡니까?
밀크씨슬이죠. 따로 챙기실 필요 없게 2성분도 들어있습니다.
이미 이 정도로 대단한데, 마지막으로 세 번째, 하루 종일 모니터 보고, 스마트폰 보고, 퇴근해서 또 유튜브 보고 저 같은 사람들을 말하죠.
그래서 눈 건강에 도움을 줄 수 있는 건강기능식품 많이 찾으실 텐데요.
이 한 포에 RTG 오메가3랑 비타민A, 루테인까지 들어있답니다.
야, 이거 도대체 몇 가지가 들어있는 거야?
아마 바쁜 일상 속에서 지속적인 피로감을 느끼시는 분들이라면
이런 구성 자체가 꽤 현실적으로 느껴지실 겁니다.
자, 공부는 다 했고, 혜택이 빠지면 섭섭하죠.
아래 더보기란과 고정 댓글에 있는 링크로 들어가셔서 구매하실 경우에
네이버페이 만원 지급, 최대 47.5% 할인까지.
와, 이거 저도 당장 추가 구매하러 가야겠는데요.
이번 기회에 데이팩에너지로 복잡한 영양제 루틴을 조금 줄이고
하루 한 포로 간편하게 건강관리 습관을 만들어 보시면 좋겠습니다.
매일 꾸준히 챙기시고 구독자분들 모두 더 가볍고
활기찬 하루 보내시길 바랍니다.
감사합니다.